[Music]
i hate california
i want to go to the east coast i want to
go where culture is like
in the world or at least connecticut or
new hampshire where writers live in the
world
schools anyway mom should just go to
city college you know with your work
ethic just go to city college and then
to jail
and then back to city college and then
maybe you'd learn to pull yourself up
and not expect
everybody to do everything lady bird
is that your given name yeah why is it
in quotes
i gave it to myself it's given to me by
me lady bird always says that she lives
on the wrong side of the tracks but i
always thought that there was like a
metaphor
but there are actual train tracks
what she did was very baller he was very
anarchist put the magazine back
she has a big heart your mom she's warm
but she's also kind of scary you can't
be scary and warm
i think you can your mom is so you're
not interested in any catholic colleges
no way i want schools like yale but not
yale because i probably couldn't get in
[Music]
you definitely couldn't get in does mom
hate me if you're tired we can sit down
i'm not tired
or dragging your feet you are so
infuriating i'm not yelling
perfect i love it you both have such
strong personalities
when is a normal time to have sex
you're having sex i just wanted it to be
special
why you're gonna have so much on special
sex in your life
[Music]
we're afraid that we will never escape
our past whatever we give you
it's never enough it's never enough
we're afraid of what the future will
bring
we're afraid we won't be loved you can't
do
anything unless you're the center of
attention we won't be liked
yeah well you know your mom's tips
they're totally fake she made one bad
decision
19 two bad decisions and we won't
succeed
i want you to be the very best version
of yourself that you can be
what if this is the best version
[Music]
what i'd really like is to be on math
olympiad but math isn't something you're
terribly strong in
that we know of yet
[Music]
you